el Ártico pronto sin hielo una
perspectiva alarmante pero muy real
Según los científicos para finales de
esta misma década su estudio publicado
en la revista nature Communications
predice que el primer mes de septiembre
sin hielo Marino En otras palabras sin
hielo compacto podría darse entre el
2030 y el 2050 para esta especialista
entrevistada por France 24 para fomentar
la educación y acción al respecto se
debe distinguir entre el pack de hielo
al que se refiere el estudio y los
casquetes polares a milenarios
respecto al hielo Marino Si volvemos a
temperaturas más bajas volveremos a
encontrarlo Porque se reforma durante el
invierno cuando baja la temperatura por
otra parte los casquetes polares que
tienen millones de años se formaron
durante las últimas glaciaciones y a
menos que volvamos a un periodo de
glaciación lo que no debería ocurrir
hasta dentro de decenas de miles de años
nunca podremos volver a formarlos
la tendencia de desaparición para los
casquetes polares es ya Irreversible
pero no para el hielo Marino que aún se
puede salvar sea cual sea la fecha
prevista para su desaparición los
científicos coinciden al afirmar que el
motivo principal son las emisiones de
gases de efecto invernadero y que su
deshielo tendrá consecuencias
irrevocables el hielo Marino funciona
como un espejo que refleja los rayos del
sol y ayuda a enfriar el Ártico
mecánicamente si su superficie se reduce
el Ártico se calentará aún más rápido
antes que otras regiones las
consecuencias una aceleración del
calentamiento global en todo el planeta
y en las latitudes medias Un aumento en
el número de fenómenos meteorológicos
extremos como las olas de calor e
incendios aforestales